et dans ce club on va parler de la
violence envers les élus elles ont
augmenté de plus de 30% la démission du
maire de Saint-Brévin est un déclencheur
dans le débat public le gouvernement a
pris des mesures mais sont-elles
suffisantes les élus sont-ils
suffisamment protégés notre démocratie
locale est-elle en danger on va en
débattre pendant plus d'une demi-heure
avec vous Françoise Gatel bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité c'est la
triste Union centriste d'Ille-et-Vilaine
vous présidez ici au Sénat la délégation
aux collectivités territoriales et à la
décentralisation romain Gaspard merci
d'être là journaliste à La Gazette des
communes en duplex avec nous
Anne-Françoise pieddalu merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes mère de
Plougrescant c'est dans les
Côtes-d'Armor et vous avez été victime
de menaces de mort et d'actes de
sabotage les freins de votre véhicule
ont été sectionnés vous allez nous en
parler dans quelques instants et Alex
évidemment est avec nous pour faire le
point factuel mais d'abord on va
commencer puisque mercredi Françoise
Gatel vous avez auditionné le maire de
Saint-Brévin il a démissionné de son
mandat après des menaces et l'incendie
de son domicile il a ensuite été reçu à
Matignon Quentin calmer nous refait le
film de cette journée
mercredi face au sénateur le maire des
missionnaires de Saint-Brevin a retracé
méticuleusement la chronologie d'un
engrenage du projet de déménagement d'un
centre de migrants près d'une école de
sa commune jusqu'à l'incendie criminel
de son domicile principal enseignement
de ce témoignage accablant le maire
s'est senti bien seul face à la violence
des opposants au centre d'accueil le
sous-préfet nous a tout simplement dit
mais les menaces vous savez moi j'en ai
tous les jours des menaces
le commandant de gendarmerie avait c'est
pas grand chose ce sont simplement des
des menaces voilà c'est de
l'intimidation
ça ne sert à rien de déposer plein de
toute façon on ne fera rien c'est la
liberté d'expression plus tard ce
mercredi Yannick morrèze assiste aux
questions au gouvernement depuis les
tribunes les miss cycles du Sénat salut
unanimement son courage tenez bon face à
la haine de l'extrême droite et des
sbires Éric Zemmour
Yannick Morez reçu ensuite à Matignon
accueilli par Elisabeth borne et la
ministre en charge des collectivités à
la clé de nouvelles annonces pour mieux
protéger les élus locaux il nous faut
évidemment arrêter cette spirale
infernale infernal de la violence faite
aux élus dans notre République c'est
absolument inacceptable voilà donc les
mères comme Monsieur le Maire sont les
garants de la sécurité publique de
l'action sociale de la protection de
l'environnement dans nos communes je
veux que tout le monde l'entende tout le
monde le sache et on doit tous se
mobiliser pour protéger nos mères des
annonces saluées par Yannick Morez mais
qui ne changeront pas la donne pour lui
il démissionnera bien de son mandat de
mer déterminé à déménager de
Saint-Brevin
on va revenir plus tard sur les annonces
du gouvernement Françoise Gatel mais le
maire de Saint-Brévin que vous avez
additionné il a dit qu'il était venu
devant vous qu'il était venu témoigner
au Sénat pour ne pas que cela se
reproduise est-ce que sa démission aura
au moins une mérite de mettre cette
question de la violence envers les élus
dans le débat public alors moi je
souhaite vraiment que cela nous aide et
à tout le monde à réfléchir et à éviter
on lui doit ça
Homère parce que c'est quand même une
folie à laquelle personne n'a pensé
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui s'est engagé
pour être qui en plus ces médecins
aujourd'hui parce que il a été une
situation très difficile il va quitter
sa commune il va changer de vie il va
même arrêter d'être médecin c'est un
truc de fou et que au-delà de la
question de la de la violence et de
l'agression il y a aussi bien d'autres
sujets sur lesquels il faut réfléchir
parce que je pense que cette situation
elle nous a tous bouleversé enfin sidéré
personne n'aurait jamais pensé aucun
sénateur que la manière dont il nous a
décrit
cette enfin cette série d'événements
nous on ne pensait pas que c'était juste
possible donc maintenant il faut bien
analyser la situation et faire que cela
ne se reproduise pas il ne s'agit pas
simplement de sanctionner ce qui
agressent les mains je crois qu'il y a
autre chose tout ça tout aussi grave
on va en parler évidemment
Anne-Françoise pied d'alu est-ce que
est-ce que selon vous ça a libéré
quelque part la parole chez les maires
ce qu'a dit le maire de Saint-Brévin
est-ce que ça fait que maintenant la
parole des mères a plus d'écho
écoutez je pense que le fait que ce
maire de Saint-Brevin qui a vécu ce
qu'il a vécu qui est quand même quelque
chose d'énorme enfin de impensable en
soi
soit amener jusqu'à faire le dépôt de sa
démission quitter sa commune et même là
j'apprends d'arrêter son métier de
médecin c'est quand même
extraordinairement grave et est-ce que
ça libérée la parole des élus
je ne sais pas si c'est la libéré en
tous les cas ça permet aux élus
d'exprimer leur mécontentement leur le
fait que ça soit horrible tout ce qui
s'est passé le fait aussi qu'on se rend
compte qu'on n'est pas seul on est parce
qu'en fait j'entends également qu'on est
quand même un certain nombre de d'élus à
avoir déjà été victime de différents
types de violences soit verbales soit
dans le pire des cas physique
et pour lequel il y a pas eu forcément
des pots de plainte ça ça m'a beaucoup
interrogé dans les débats qui ont eu
lieu là ces derniers temps d'entendre
qu'il y avait autant de d'élus au final
qui se manifeste maintenant et qui
disent ben non voilà elle m'est arrivé
ici il m'est arrivé ça mais en fait j'ai
pas fait de dépôt de plainte donc moi je
pense franchement qu'il va falloir que
au niveau du Pack Sécurité que j'ai bien
écouté il y a des choses intéressantes
je pense qu'il y a surtout aussi falloir
travailler maintenant parce que ce n'est
qu'un démarrage je pense pas de sécurité
il faut continuer à avancer c'est que
lorsque un élu se sent menacé
temps verbalement alors pire
physiquement et il est la possibilité
d'exprimer cette crainte sans forcément
s'asseoir le stade du dépôt plainte par
exemple en ce qui me concerne avant de
faire mon dépôts plein donc pour mes
flexible de véhicule coupé chez moi
j'avais été quelques temps avant victime
de menaces de mort et donc c'est très
grave mais je n'avais pas fait de dépôt
de plainte à ce moment-là et c'est vrai
que je m'interroge maintenant sur
pourquoi j'ai pas fait cette époque
plainte vous voyez c'est moi même je
nous dis pourquoi j'ai pas fait d'autant
plus que je vois bien que c'est quelque
part un petit peu la façon de faire d'un
certain nombre d'élus en fait on se dit
avec recul maintenant je me dis bon
faire des pots de plainte ça paraît très
lourd
ça veut dire aussi qu'il y a des
conséquences derrière on sait bien que
quand on fait un peu plein derrière bon
ben il y a l'enquête voir une
instruction on sait que c'est lourd et
donc est-ce qu'on est prêt à vivre ça en
plus des violences verbales et dont on
est victime par exemple
je ne sais pas et moi là ce qui a fait
que j'ai fait mon dépôt de plainte c'est
parce que il y a eu un passage à lattes
c'est ma sphère privée qui a été donc
agressée puisque c'est devant mon
domicile mon ma voiture a été je pense
la nuit sectionnée au niveau des freins
les quatre freins les quatre flexibles
voilà là je dis bon là c'est trop grave
j'y vais je fais un dépôt de plainte
mais moi je pense qu'il faudrait qu'il y
ait quelque chose entre ce qu'on appelle
la main courante mais qui en réalité
n'a pas de valeur réelle et n'est pas
forcément pris en considération et le
dépôt de plainte c'est à dire qu'il est
une démarche intermédiaire je sais pas
laquelle il faut y réfléchir et qui
permettent de libérer la parole des élus
et qu'il puisse le dire et que ça puisse
être pris en compte
merci Anne-Françoise pédali pour cette
semaine je restais avec nous évidemment
dans ce club vous entendez ce que dit la
mère Françoise Gatel j'imagine que c'est
pas la première fois vous entendez ce
type de témoignage mais c'est quand même
assez poignant de dire ben on n'a pas
porté plainte j'ai hésité finalement je
me suis demandé pourquoi je l'avais pas
fait et puis on comprend que c'est une
charge supplémentaire finalement ce
dépôt de plainte pour les élus il faut
adapter tout ça je veux d'abord lui
exprimer toute mon toute mon amitié ma
solidarité parce que je pense que ce
qu'elle déc qui est qui est vrai et vous
l'avez dit ça arrive peut-être pas de
manière aussi grave mais c'est menace
dans beaucoup de communes c'est juste
irréel pour les mains je pense que vous
avez raison quand vous dites moi j'ai
pas porté plainte c'est compliqué mais
qu'en plus
quel maire peut aujourd'hui enfin hier
en tout cas pouvait penser qu'une menace
de mort contre lui etait quelque chose
qui pouvait s'avérer à un moment ça
n'iront pense que ce sont des choses qui
n'arrivent pas et aujourd'hui les choses
aillent ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'il y
a vraiment une prise de conscience dans
notre société que ça peut arriver comme
ça peut arriver à un policier ou à un
pompier et qu'il y ait un lieu
d'accompagnement
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on voit
d'ailleurs les associations
départementales demain crée des sortes
de groupes de parole où vous avez un
temps vous pouvez changer en disant
voilà moi j'ai des menaces j'ai des
choses un peu bizarres comment on fait
il ne faut pas laisser le maire seul
avec conseils il faut effectivement que
la gendarmerie la justice
accompagne tout ça mais c'est juste
quelque chose d'irréel de comprendre à
un moment que parce que vous êtes engagé
pour rendre service aux gens et
quelqu'un qui vous menace anonymement de
mort et que ça peut aller
jusqu'au fait que on va toucher au frein
de votre voiture c'est c'est
comme disent les enfants on est dans un
monde de ouf non mais c'est vous voyez
je même quand on parle on a des yeux
comme ça parce qu'on se dit mais est-ce
que c'est possible et d'autant romain
que ces violences envers les élus elles
sont en augmentation oui oui quand on
prend 2022 par rapport à 2021 c'est 32%
d'augmentation selon les chiffres du
ministère de l'intérieur rien que sur ce
trimestre là par rapport à l'année
dernière c'est 3% d'augmentation encore
donc on voit une forte hausse et puis
c'est ce qui a été dit tout le monde ne
porte pas plein donc quand on prend par
exemple au dernier des mères le
baromètre qui est fait chaque année sur
les incivilités alors on parle ça va de
l'insulte à l'agression ça peut enfin il
y a une marche qui est large quand même
c'est 63% des maires qui se disent
victimes
d'insultes ou d'agressions c'est quand
même des chiffres assez impressionnants
et on se dit que il y a maintenant 4 ans
il y avait la mort du maire de signe
pour des dépôts sauvages les élus avec
qui on on échange régulièrement nous
disent la situation c'est plutôt empiré
et en tout cas ça ne s'est pas améliorer
malgré cet électrochoc à l'époque d'un
maire
qui meurt à cause d'une altercation
après un dépôt sauvage où il était allé
rechercher les les déposants du du dépôt
ça c'est des vrais interrogations et
quand on prend dans le détail c'est
quand même 165 agressions physiques
l'année dernière c'est pas rien
là-dessus avec des cas parfois très très
grave donc il y a eu des mesures mais
est-ce que c'est suffisant c'est toute
la question il y a eu des mesures parce
c'est vrai que on se souvient que la la
mort du maire de cygnes ça effectivement
comme le dit romain était un électrochoc
il y a eu cette fameuse loi engagement
et proximité importée par Sébastien
Lecornu à l'époque et pourtant romain le
dit la situation continue d'empirer
pourquoi Françoise Gatel parce que je
pense qu'effectivement après la mort du
maire de Chine on a fait des choses
protection fonctionnelle
des élus un lien renforcé entre le
procureur et les mers donc il y a eu des
discussions et que le sujet pour moi
n'est pas que celui de la réaction que
l'on doit avoir quand il y a une
agression c'est déjà le vrai sujet c'est
de dire mais pourquoi on en est là et
que je pense qu'il y a je l'ai dit
mercredi dans ma question d'actualité je
pense qu'il y a d'abord une vraie
question d'éducation on sort de
plusieurs années de bashing des élus
enfin rappelez-vous quand même les élus
c'est des gens un peu bizarres ils font
des choses étranges la justice ça se
fait enfin c'est quand même
balance donc ça veut dire que à un
moment il y a une forme d'irrespect ou
de déconsidérations par rapport aux élus
et que le maire il a perdu ce rôle qui
l'incarnait de quelqu'un qu'on respecte
parce que le maire c'est Monsieur ou
Madame machin mais c'est quelqu'un qui
incarne l'état donc respect donc ça
c'est totalement effondré et
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une société
où il y a de la violence verbale enfin
je dis dans certaines assemblées c'était
remarquable l'exercice de la violence
verbale qui a un moment se transforme en
couple parce que on n'arrive pas à se
faire comprendre en criant voilà et
c'est un peu partout comme ça et que nos
concitoyens qu'on adore ils sont parfois
plein de contradictions et d'une
exigence par rapport à leur à leurs élus
et donc quand ils sont pas contents ils
se défoule sur les élus donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut éduquer ça c'est la
première chose ensuite il faut
sanctionner et vraiment je dis
aujourd'hui qu'il faut qu'on revienne
sur cette disposition que le Sénat avait
voté sur la sanction concours un
agresseur d'élus amer qui fait son
mandat de manière correctile et agressé
il doit être considéré comme quelqu'un
qui représente l'autorité de l'État
comme un policier il faut sanctionner
pour donner des exemples et puis il faut
prévenir empêcher ce quand même regardez
ce que nous a dit le maire de
Saint-Brevin et d'autres je pense que la
situation à Saint-Brévin
a eu un défaut d'appréciation au
démarrage et tout au long de son
déroulement et que le truc il est un peu
parti envahi gravement parce que je
pense ou en tout cas il faudra
s'interroger là-dessus et on le fera
dans les auditions je pense qu'il y a eu
une appréciation totalement insuffisante
du risque qui ce fameux principe de
précaution qui est dans la Constitution
qui souvent nous embarrasse ça nous
principe de précaution si on peut
l'utiliser de manière intelligente en
disant comment on peut prendre soin des
maires et de la République c'est le
sujet aujourd'hui et ça n'est pas qu'en
augmentant les sanctions on va pas
mettre on peut pas mettre un gendarme
derrière chaque élu 24 heures sur 24
mais il faut organiser les choses pour
limiter les risques sécurisés que comme
l'a dit Madame le Maire tout à l'heure
il y a un lieu où vraiment il y ait un
échange et que les associations des
lieux qui ont bien commencé prennent le
temps de bain et conformes les élus à ça
de nouvelles annonces qui ont été faites
ensuite à la démission du maire de
Saint-Brévin par le gouvernement
effectivement la semaine dernière la
mise en charge des collectivités
Dominique Faure annoncé la création d'un
centre d'analyses et de lutte contre les
atteintes aux élus ce centre était une
demande des élus locaux il va permettre
de mieux suivre ce type de violence
d'analyser le phénomène et de coordonner
la réponse des forces de l'ordre sur le
terrain et puis le gouvernement va
lancer ce qu'il appelle un pack sécurité
pour protéger les élus avec d'abord 3400
référents atteintes aux élus qui seront
mobilisés dans les brigades de
gendarmerie dans les commissariats pour
offrir un point de contact et de
dialogues avec les élus pour parler des
violences et des pressions donc dont ils
sont victimes le dispositif alarme élu
va être renforcé alors comment ça
fonctionne en fait quand un élu se sent
menacé et bien il peut appeler le 17 la
police et être secouru rapidement faire
l'objet d'une vigilance renforcée de la
part des forces de l'ordre les préfets
se sont vus également rappeler le le
principe une menace une évaluation pour
permettre une analyse plus fine des
différentes menaces qui pèsent parfois
sur un élu et puis les forces de l'ordre
devront aller à davantage vers ces mères
pour leur permettre de porter plainte à
n'importe quel moment et dans le lieu où
il le souhaite le souhaite et puis enfin
le gouvernement ave veut aggraver les
sanctions pénales on va écouter sur ce
point la ministre Dominique fort faire
en sorte que la sanction quand on quand
on
s'attaque à un élu la sanction sur la
même nature que la sanction qui est
aujourd'hui
conduite auprès d'un de quelqu'un qui
s'attaque un gendarme ou un policier et
donc ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui on
n'a pas pu le passer dans la locmi mais
on va passer le plus vite possible cette
loi ça va permettre malgré tout de
monter jusqu'à 10 ans d'emprisonnement
quand on s'attaque à un élu et de monter
à 150000 euros d'amende on le rappelle
se durcissement des sanctions pénales
pour les agresseurs d'élus avaient été
introduit et voté par le Sénat l'automne
dernier dans le projet de loi
d'orientation du ministère de
l'intérieur mais la mesure avait été
retoquée par le Conseil constitutionnel
pour des raisons juridiques
est-ce que ces mesures vous avez
l'impression qu'elles sont à la hauteur
qu'elles répondent à ce que vous vivez
quotidiennement sur le terrain
alors concernant les différentes
propositions qui sont par exemple de
permettre qu'un élu puisse être entendu
dans le dépôt d'une plainte dans un
espace qui lui convient le mieux pour ma
part ça c'est déjà produit ainsi puisque
les gendarmes sont venus en mairie
recueillaient ma plainte donc déjà là je
trouve que c'était quand même un confort
plutôt que de se rendre en gendarmerie
pour faire ce dépôt donc pour ma part je
trouvais que c'était effectivement
quelque chose de bien de la même manière
que sur le fait de pouvoir être inscrit
sur un numéro de téléphone qui fait que
lorsqu'on appelle le 17 automatiquement
on apparaît comme menacé pour ma part ça
c'est aussi déjà fait on l'a proposé au
moment où j'ai eu les menaces de mort
puisque j'avais quand même informé la
sous-préfecture et les gendarmes sans
faire mon dépôt de plat mais il y a
quand même eu cette le fait que je ne
sois rapproché d'eux et à ce moment-là
ils m'ont conseillé donc ils m'ont fait
inscrire sur ce fameux numéro sachant
que par contre on apparaît comme
personne menacée et je pense que là dans
l'évolution qui va être amené à être
porté ça sera sans doute inscrit mère
menacée ou élue menacé je pense que
c'est important que ça apparaisse
d'abord ça permettra sans doute aussi de
faire des statistiques beaucoup plus
intéressantes sur le nombre de d'élus
qui sont amenés à se sentir menacé
donc pour moi ça s'est passé déjà j'ai
envie de dire à la différence du maire
de Saint-Brevin je veux quand même
apporter le fait dans mon témoignage que
ça soit le sous-préfet le préfet le
parquet donc via le procureur les
gendarmes j'ai vraiment été vraiment été
bien entouré bien entendu écouter et
entendu
ça c'est quelque chose qui fait aussi
que après lorsque j'étais mon dépôt de
plainte et depuis que les pots de
plainte qui a donc l'enquête qui est
quand même ouvert pour tentative
d'homicide et menace de mort réitérer à
l'encontre d'un élu donc une personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique sont
quand même des faits effectivement qui
sont graves donc maintenant la démarche
va suivre son cours au niveau de la
justice mais à mon niveau par exemple
comme les menaces portaient aussi sur la
mairie bon il y a eu une équipe de
gendarmes qui se sont donc déplacés en
mairie pour nous conseiller voir un
petit peu comment et la mairie en termes
de sécurité par rapport aux parce que le
contexte dans lequel je suis moins ce
qu'il faut voir c'est que par derrière
ce sont également les élus et les agents
communaux aussi qui se sentent quelque
part menacées donc voyez cet après-midi
par exemple il va avoir une cellule
psychologique qui va être mise en place
pour les agents communaux alors demande
donc suite à ce qui s'est passé parce
que du coup la mairie on l'ouvre au
compte-goutte on nous ouvre qu'en
fonction des personnes qui viennent
c'est pas une ouverture comme c'était
jusqu'à présent ouverte à toute personne
qui peut être amenée à vouloir venir
demander un service en mairie ont
beaucoup bien évidemment nos comptes on
vérifie et donc ça oui c'est c'est
énorme c'est quand on voit les
conséquences qui à part derrière c'est
aussi tout ça ouais Françoise Gatel
c'est vrai qu'on a été saisi dans
l'ordre du témoignage du maire de
Saint-Brevin par sa description de son
abandon finalement par l'État mais on
entend aussi beaucoup d'élus comme
Anne-Françoise pédalu dire non mais moi
j'ai été soutenu j'ai été soutenue par
le préfet
ça dépend aussi beaucoup du préfet ce
dans le détail à une inégalité ça dépend
vraiment des cas faut pas généraliser
l'abandon de l'état non voilà on peut
pas généraliser ça renvoie plusieurs
choses d'abord l'importance du corps
préfectoral et de sa formation et
qu'après tout ça c'est aussi une
question de relation humaine d'écoute et
d'attention et puis je pense qu'il y a
des départements enfin dans mon
département d'Ille-et-Vilaine c'est
comme c'est une spécificité bretonne je
n'en sais je veux pas dire qu'on est
plus protégé mais en tout cas dans le
département d'Ille-et-Vilaine moi je
connais la mobilisation de la
gendarmerie le gendarme il a le portable
du maire et qui a une relation régulière
donc peut-être que la ministre elle veut
généraliser bonne pratique ça c'est
parfait définir de la méthode donc on
peut pas
c'est très bien vous voulez saluer ou il
augmente
si on avait rien dit vous voyez bien en
France il y a une émotion un truc
épouvantable faut un truc qui nous donne
l'impression que ça va être miraculeux
ça n'arrivera plus jamais sauf que moi
je suis un peu catholique mais je crois
pas toujours miracle et que je pense que
il y a bien d'autres choses derrière on
l'a dit éduqué protégé trait autrement
avec l'État donc quel dise en généralise
on systématis ça veut dire qu'on prend
conscience qu'il y a des et que ça n'est
pas normal donc moi je je salue tout ça
après dans ce cas décrit le maire c'est
la question que vous posez c'est comment
est-ce qu'à un moment si tout ça ça
s'avère voilà comment est-ce que une
décision d'État sur un sujet aussi
sensible de cada même si elle
Saint-Brevin ça s'est très bien passé on
le met près d'une école ça génère de
l'émotion des parents tout le monde
commence un peu
à avoir peur avoir de la crainte et puis
dans cette situation est-ce qu'on peut
parler de l'instrumentalisation de tout
ça et des extrémistes parce que ce qui a
aussi fait des rappeler les choses c'est
que il y a des extrémistes là en
l'occurrence d'extrêmement on a la même
chose à gauche dans d'autres sujets
voilà
qui ont un moment instrumentalisé ce
sujet en Bretagne quelques semaines
avant et donc on a vu comment l'extrême
droite s'emparer de ce sujet et que ça a
fait une sorte
d'incendie politicien d'incendie
sociétale et qu'on est plus simplement
dans une situation entre guillemets plus
ordinaire ou le maire il a géré une
situation difficile et que la question
que moi je me pose sur la description de
la situation de mer c'est est-ce qu'un
moment il y a une appréciation de la
situation et du risque exactement le
principe de précaution on passe notre
vie quand on est élu à devoir faire
attention pour qu'il n'arrive pas
d'incendie pour que ils n'arrivent pas
enfin qui n'arrivent rien quel que soit
et que là est-ce qu'à mon cadastre quand
même un truc qui soulève de l'émotion
même là où ça se passe bien il y a quand
même de l'agitation politique très
dangereuse en ce moment des extrémies
est-ce qu'on a et le maire il sait aussi
retrouver au milieu d'un phénomène dans
un contexte politique qui est très lourd
et très grave et ça faut qu'on tire les
leçons de ça aujourd'hui
il y a une hausse de la menace d'extrême
droite un peu d'extrême gauche mais
quand on voit la menace la plus violente
c'est quand même celle d'extrême droite
qui augmente et par exemple RuPaul
montrait que 45% des arrestations
de terrorisme d'extrême droite c'était
en France là dessus on parle de 3000
militants c'est pas un nombre si énorme
que ça mais par contre
tous les services de renseignement le
disent il y a une hausse de la menace il
y a une organisation qui est plus forte
et ça c'est c'est assez inquiétant parce
que sur les les 10 derniers attentats
politiques des jouets il y en a quand
même sept qui viennent d'une menace
d'extrême droite et c'est un peu sous
les radars parce que on parle des
agressions parlent des démissions c'est
des vrais sujets mais il y a une
problématique particulière sur comment
est-ce qu'on traite cette
violence-là et ce militantisme là qui
est assez dangereux pour terminer plus
généralement sur les conséquences de
cette augmentation des violences je vais
peut-être commencer par vous
Anne-François spiezdalude dans quel état
d'esprit vous êtes aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous êtes découragé est-ce que vous
avez eu envie de démissionner est-ce que
vous avez envie d'être à nouveau
candidate
alors pour répondre dans l'ordre à vos
questions pour ma part je ne souhaite
pas je l'ai annoncé je ne souhaite pas
démissionner alors je ne souhaite pas
démissionner parce que quelque part
j'aurais le sentiment qu'en le faisant
je donnerai raison d'une certaine
manière à ceux qui sont passés à l'acte
en sectionnant mais flexibles et ça je
ne veux pas bon c'est vrai aussi que je
suis pas dans la situation d'une mère de
Saint-Brévin donc à chaque chose et à
chaque type de d'agression je pense
qu'on peut avoir aussi une réaction
différente par contre bon je ne me
représenterai pas mais je me
représenterai pas non pas par rapport à
ce qui vient de se passer j'avais déjà
décidé de ne pas me représenter c'est
mon deuxième mandat de maire j'étais
précédemment adjointe ça fera 18 ans
d'élus j'estime que chacun doit prendre
sa part dans une collectivité qu'un élu
n'est pas là pour rester il est aussi là
pour passer flambeau et l'important qui
est d'autres personnes d'autres
habitants qui se mobilisent et qui
prennent en charge tout ce qui est à
prendre en charge quand quand on émerge
l'ensemble des domaines dans lequel on
doit intervenir ça va d'une chose très
simple à une chose beaucoup plus
compliquée à des choses beaucoup plus
compliquées et donc pour ma part en tous
les cas ce que je peux dire c'est que je
suis très intéressé par cette fonction
c'est aussi pour ça que je me suis
représenté au mandat précédent
c'est-à-dire que j'apprends énormément
donc c'est très enrichissant et ça c'est
quelque chose que les élus qui se
présentent ont tous je pense on est là
pour l'intérêt général quand on se
présente on n'est pas là pour soi on est
là pour faire les choses au bénéfice des
habitants voilà et donc pour ma part je
me représenterai pas mais j'aurais quand
même 69 ans à la fin de mon mandat
j'estime que c'est bien il faut qu'il y
ait des jeunes aussi qui prennent la
relève et bon d'une certaine manière
quand certains disent Yaka faucon il y a
pas de problème mais
la question c'est c'est est-ce que avec
tout ce qui se passe la relève est là
aujourd'hui Françoise Gatel est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui notre démocratie locale
est en danger
alors moi j'aurais d'abord saluer les
maires parce que quand même vous rendez
compte de ce que dit Madame le Main
est-ce que du chemin c'est des gens
formidables tous les jours ils invendent
des trucs globalement ils font un
travail formidable et s'il n'était pas
là je dis parfois quand je vais à des
cérémonies de veau j'enfermé les yeux
deux minutes et imaginez ce que votre
vie s'il y avait plus d'élus si la
mérite on n'est pas donc sont des gens
vraiment courageux et je pense qu'il
faut ils sont pas au dessus des lois
mais ils exercent une fonction qui amène
à ce qu'il soit pris en considération
donc il faut déjà redonner du respect je
pense qu'il y a vraiment un rôle
d'éducation en 2020 par rapport à votre
question sur qu'est-ce que ça va donner
de ça il y avait 106 communes où il y a
pas eu de candidat moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
faut vraiment vouloir être mais parce
que si vous travaillez si vous avez une
famille c'est compliqué de tout
conjuguer parce que c'est un engagement
personnel familial professionnel c'est
très lourd et puis c'est du 24 24 c'est
ce que dit vous êtes mère vous dites 1 2
3 nuits dans la semaine et vous êtes
tout le temps un truc dans la tête vous
m'arrêtez ça vous prend le ça vous prend
le cerveau si je puis dire et d'un côté
heureusement et que je pense qu'il faut
d'abord que on est aussi quant à main et
élu avant les former au finances à
l'urbanie c'est parfait mais aujourd'hui
il faut les former à cette pression
morale il faut les accompagner parce
qu'il y a une charge sur les familles et
puis sincèrement le métier de main enfin
la fonction de main pardon aujourd'hui
il faut avouer que il y a pas grand
chose pour faciliter l'exercice tout est
très compliqué donc c'est comment l'État
accompagne les maires pour permettre
comment on arrête de leur complexifier
la vie et de faire comme
une augmentation des indemnités oui il y
a la protection il y a la sécurisation
il faut que quelqu'un qui s'engage comme
mère quand il arrête il faut qu'il
puisse retrouver un travail il faut que
on reconnaisse sa contribution à la
société comment on le fait pour les
pompiers puis surtout
c'est vraiment comment on lui donne les
moyens d'agir pour conclure romain il y
a inquiétude sur 2026 alors qu'il y a
déjà des démissions record des nombres
de démission record oui oui mais il faut
il faut il faut pas l'oublier que les
élus en plus les plus touchés par ces
agressions par ces démissions c'est les
petites communes c'est des élus qui sont
quasi bénévoles qui se donnent qui
cumulent souvent avec un métier à côté
et donc
c'est une vraie vocation et avec le
vieillissement et avec l'impuissance et
parfois aussi le consumérisme des
habitants bah il y a des questionnements
pour certains pour repartir et pour
trouver une relève et dans des petites
communes ou déjà c'était compliqué de de
former des listes avec 11 conseils
municipaux parce qu'il y a aussi cette
difficulté là comment ça sera en 2026
c'est une vraie interrogation merci pour
ce débat je vais remercier
Anne-Françoise merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous et de nous avoir apporté
votre témoignage merci infiniment
Françoise Gatel romain vous restez avec
nous on va regarder la rue de presse
régionale
[Musique]
Alex on commence par La Voix du Nord qui
revient sur la mort de trois policiers
mais oui après le choc autour de cet
accident à Villeneuve-d'Ascq place au
temps de l'enquête et de l'hommage
l'enquête d'abord le procureur livré
plusieurs éléments hier sur ce qui s'est
passé le chauffeur du véhicule qui a
percuté la voiture des policiers et qui
est lui aussi décide décédé était
ivre et sous stupéfiant au moment des
faits il était engagé à contresens sur
une route départementale son compteur de
vitesse était resté bloqué à 120 km/h le
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin
a annoncé un hommage national à Roubaix
pour les trois policiers décédés le choc
également après une attaque au couteau
hier à l'hôpital de Reims déséquilibré à
poignarder une infirmière et une
secrétaire à l'hôpital Maison Blanche et
on a appris ce matin que l'infirmière
était décédée elle était âgée de 38 ans
la deuxième victime et grièvement
blessée mais son pronostic vital n'est
pas engagée le ministre de la Santé
François Brune a annoncé la création
d'un comité pour renforcer la sécurité à
des champignons alors que les violences
contre les médecins augmentaient de 23%
en 2022 les ravages de la cuisine de
plusieurs journaux régionaux la
consommation de cocaïne en France a été
multipliée par trois en 20 ans et se
développe un peu partout dans le pays
notamment dans la Nièvre c'est à la Une
aujourd'hui du populaire du centre cela
s'explique par un prix en baisse un
marché étendu jusque dans les zones
rurales une consommation qui explose
également dans la région de Marseille
c'est à la Une du journal La Provence
toutes les catégories sociales sont
concernées aujourd'hui par la cocaïne ce
n'est plus et bien la panache de
certaines soirées
Elisabeth borne a dévoilé hier son plan
pour diminuer nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre ah oui c'est à la une du
Républicain Lorrain et de la Dépêche du
Midi le gouvernement cible la
décarbonation des usines et le
changement des chaudières au fioul ce
plan doit réduire de moitié nos
émissions en 2030 par rapport à 1990
avant d'atteindre la neutralité carbone
en 2050 mais la question du coût de
cette transition écologique pose
question c'est d'ailleurs la une du
Picard aujourd'hui un rapport de France
stratégie estime que cette décarbonation
va demander un investissement public
supplémentaire de 66 milliards d'euros
par an et ce rapport prône une hausse de
la fiscalité sur le patrimoine financier
des plus aisés merci beaucoup Alex pour
cette rue de presse la Une de La Gazette
des communes cette semaine romain accès
au droit quand les services publics se
rapprochent des usagers oui c'est les
dire c'est toute la question du rapport
à l'usager et de comment est-ce qu'on
fait pour que ils aient accès et que il
y ait moins de non recours sur tout un
tas de services et de prestations et
c'est à dire
dans d'avoir été avec nous merci à tous
de nous avoir suivis vous pouvez voir ou
revoir cette émission sur public
sénat.fr on se retrouve demain et
prochain rendez-vous c'est à 18h Thomas
Hulk sens publique très bonne journée
[Musique]